Street Fighter 5 has an eclectic cast of
ninjas wrestlers and mysterious figures
but not every contender makes the cut
I'm Tony this is a GameSpot news update
and these are Street Fighter fives
rejected characters Capcom revealed
concept art for a handful of characters
that didn't quite make it into the
latest Street Fighter these include a
quote fighting president in a white suit
who was also cut from Street Fighter 4
also cut was an odd female character
whose clothes would fall off as she
thought I don't think we're missing out
on anything there one of the cooler
designs was a shadow loo soldier with a
slight resemblance to the predator
there's always a chance we could see
these guys as DLC down the road or even
in the inevitable Street Fighter 6 this
is just the first wave of rejected
fighters Capcom will reveal you can head
over to the Capcom fighters Network to
read descriptions of each scrap design
and if you want to keep up with all the
latest Street Fighter news you're
already in the right place